the stunt that got cut where you're
under water in a chair tied to a chair
like that gave me anxiety just hearing
that because I don't like being
underwater in fact I'd rather be in
space alone than under water alone
I totally hear that that was one of them
like the most difficult thing I've ever
had to do at work was it traumatic was
it traumatic
it was I I think about that and I go
like I can't breathe and it wasn't even
in the film made me so mad what what
exactly happened so they put you under
there you didn't have any kind of uh
well it was just a it was a giant tank
and it was used for the second film
because my characters
spoiler alert dead and
um
she's in this ethereal universe and so
they were going to try to take our
movements underwater and make it look
like we're weren't we weren't underwater
I think there's a Green Day music video
like this where like you know like the
hair starts to float and my boobs were
like up to here which is one of the
reasons why it really didn't work
because I'm in a tank top and like my
foods are here you know everything
floats
um so we trained to be underwater doing
dialogue and they sunk the entire
apartment in a tank underwater
uh and we had to be restrained not
restrained but weighed down
so that I could sit in a chair because
as you float
um and it had to be deep enough where
you could get lights and cameras and
things in there
and the director spoke to us through
like a speaker underwater and I had a
diver at my feet who was ready to give
me oxygen when I needed it but it wasn't
an you know it had a roof like I was in
an apartment
so it had like a an escape hatch that
you had to swim to find but it was also
really dark you know and it was Panic
inducing and I really was just the whole
time working on like I can do this like
I'm just taking deep breaths I'm only 10
feet underwater like it's not a big deal
or you know it was awful and every time
I needed you go like this and they come
and they give you and I would Panic that
like if I don't blow I don't have enough
air left to blow out the bubbles and
then be able to take a deep breath if I
choke on this thing on 10 15 feet
underwater that's a long way up to like
be choking you know yeah I I had the
same thing on the pilot of Smallville I
thought they'd fire me I was in a
12-foot tank and listen to this they put
me in a port like the Porsche that Clark
Rescues Me from and in there and they
put weights on me and I could hear the
director and it's this murky water it's
supposed to be a lake and
and I freak out and go up to the top and
like the third time I go to Tom I go
They're Gonna fire me I can't do this I
can't do this I can't this is I I'm I'm
having flashbacks it was just yeah it's
awful I finally got it and it and it
worked but it was absolutely
terrifying it's horrible yeah and I
didn't have to really have my eyes open
your eyes had to be open that was yeah
so that was the other thing I think that
made it worse was we were talking to
each other we couldn't have bubbles
coming out because it was supposed to
not look like we were underwater so we
had to like
you have to release a little air clear
all the bubbles from your face make sure
you can open your mouth on top without a
bubble coming out do the dialogue scene
and hang out there and wait take a
breath and do it all over again and keep
and have your eyes open as I could
barely see him well they didn't
anticipate was that there's particles
and things in
the pillows that were attached to the
couch the wood
credenza whatever the [__] like things
had it started to float into the water
and both Ryan and I got really severe
eye infections are you serious we
couldn't open our eyes for like two days
did they have to like cancel production
for two days yes